did you have a nice Easter Andy I did I
actually my family and I went to
Illinois to be with my side of the
family my care goby I can tell him I
said hi so no we went to Illinois for
just Easter weekend and we went on
Easter morning to a brunch at this very
nice place and kids loved it and it was
all my brothers and sisters and my mom
and all their kids and there was an
Easter Bunny there and so the kids were
happy to see the Easter Bunny and
afterwards because we're so rarely
together as a group a family reunion
yeah as kind of a family ruined we said
it let's go outside and take a picture
of the entire group and we got we got
ahead of stranger somebody walking by
take the picture which I think we have
here yeah and there's that's me and my
brothers and sisters and all our kids
and then the Easter Bunny's there and
nobody asked the Easter Bunny in a
culture really he just stepped in yeah
he yeah I assume it's Aggie yeah just
stepped right in there and there's
Easter Bunny right in the picture he
doesn't look good no I mean it looks
like he's got a he's got a parasite
a liquor store with money and he's
living with us now
in our garage sleeping in my wife's car
seems like a creep
you